[Music]
this is insane I can't believe that he
made this island the amount of bottles
that I've sent off to be recycled when
really I could have my own Island I
better get started on my own private
island final Island has generated more
than 3 million hits so we set sail from
Mexico to get the truth behind reach
arts plastic paradise this whole idea of
doing a floating island came to me in a
vision and I saw a whole like Garden of
Eden paradise on a beautiful ocean all
done totally clean and it was all
floating on the trash of the world on
Wow
[Music]
so are we how in the name of Avion has
rechart built this trash tastic real
estate
[Music]
beneath the island in the water our next
cells that contain 170,000 reclaimed
plastic bottles the island measures
eight to two feet or 25 meters in width
91 feet 28 meters in length on it he
gets his own three-bedroom house with
electricity and Wi-Fi wow this is the
biodegradable toilet it's always with
leaves on the top then when it comes to
high I have this thing here and I can
take it out and it's soil for the garden
but why doesn't reach arts toilet house
and whole island sink like a stone
underneath the island Richard has
plastic bottles with air trapped inside
them inside nets the net see underneath
wooden pallets on top of those wooden
pallets are old plywood covered in sand
and into that he plants mangrove trees
mangrove trees provide the perfect glue
to hold this island together they really
like the salty nature of the ocean the
roots are also aerial which means that
they can leap around under the water and
then come back above ground so this is a
few years old but you'd never be able to
pull that out it's just holding the
whole island together yeah second
Nicholas Anya you have trash and then
you have earth and then you have trash
and earth again
is this floating lasagna built to last
one of the problems with using water
bottles is that they degrade in the Sun
from the UV so richard has been really
smart about putting his water bottles
and sacks underneath the island so none
of the sunlight can hit it it also
encourages seafoam and coal to grow
around the bottles which protect them
further so the nature is actually
preserving the trash and without the
trash all of the trees on this island
would just die and sink into the
saltwater